No, this is the branch of the dark soul tree. It's the
latest one. I'll introduce it later,
but I'm going to do the experience I'm announcing after this, but I'm going to do a little map without that experience.  I wonder
if I'll just introduce it. It's cool to say that
this is a
booster.
Matt is like this this time
. Well, even the 8 screenshots knew that it would be released
.  I wonder if the person's legs are a little about the knee length,
right? I'm telling you if you're going out, right? I've
always
wanted to tell you a little about that story.
This time, the 8 action meeting unique to Dark Souls 3ds
has deepened the action of the sword fight battle, but there are
actions specific to weapons, but I will show you this time as well.
I'm thinking of showing a little action to the arsenal that I haven't done
. I have this thief's sword, but
this thief's dagger has
a tactic.  I'd like to show you what's next. The
tactics of exploring thieves are
called He Quick Steps,
which allows you to take a fairly quick step on the web
.  8
You can use it in the member wing with both hands.
This is a normal flooring, isn't it?
When I used the point, there was a gauge on the upper left, but it started to consume the blue gauge
.
This is rolling, but
that's good
.
It's good to use this, isn't it?
Gold is drawn behind the opponent.
Thank you for being a dagger thief.
Yes
, this blue gauge is blue on the beach, which was also a network test,
but this time it can be recovered by using this.  Is like s and two
. This is a tactic called this quick step,
so it moves very fast.  If you can
do it, you used a pen
again. After Putin, that's right. That's
good. 5 It's light enough to make that happy movement. If
you step on it, you'll recover.
I think I'd like to see the continuation throw. I
introduced it a little when I was in the rooms of this in 3, and I received it from rolling
. There was just a lot of talk,
but the tactics of the outer
chamber were  Well, there are things that can be fired in rapid
succession, and there are also things that you can go and hit with a feeling, so I'm
using voice registration now, but I'm opening 2 so that I can move more like a thief
.  I just caught Bucks, but there is also andy Sai-chan's
wording,
so when there are a lot of enemies like this, I
will tell you a
line drawing.
After this, those who will have an experience session from this weekend can actually experience it.
Imasaki If you walk a little,
such
parents are spreading, so I hope you will enjoy the
experience only in the future.
It's not a mountain, but I don't like it.
I'm glad if you can experience it for a while while thinking about what it's like to see various things
.
I'm curious about it, and in light clothes that stand in this way, it's a weapon-specific action that is said to be 8 tactics, and it has a
more character-like movement and something like the end bar of the action,
so that's it.  I want to be myself, or I
can create a character that suits my play style, so I think that role play
will expand,
so Yu-san's free play style.
I hope you can try various things, so